150 okay here we go 115 players have
entered this guy I think I played him
twice in the last tournament okay I'm
gonna put pressure on the dark squares I
should have given check you're still in
that pond
give me the dark square Bishop now give
me the dark square bishop I don't know
soften this I could have taken that open
up the light squares
what's this queen doing ready for this
like I get this pawn with check Queen
trade coming up let's free up with my
light square bishop my dark square
bishop wants to play hire me hit this
rook stop the night from pivoting here
get my king up this is gonna be the
perfect home bishop check is not an
inconvenience stop the knight from
posting up my rook doing something I
should have taken his pond now I have
him and let's do that lets just take
here I have a tsunami of pawns a tsunami
of pawns the king is looking to get
mated he is definitely looking at mated
I think pigs
I have wild pigs here I'm gonna throw in
some checks with tempo that's made
actually back to tournament - oh my
goodness three sixes are in there who
okay efore oh I have to play Knight f3
so somebody was saying to play Knight f3
Occulus was saying play Knight f3
because it's the most aggressive start
now even he didn't say that I'm putting
I'm putting words in his mouth now okay
let's get developed open Sicilian
yeah Castle they're neglecting the king
side I have to be cautious of the c-4
square and I might play Knight d5 this
covered if push I think I'd do this oh
not now though tricky knight is pinned
Knight takes bishop takes to cover this
as otherwise I'm dropping upon here and
I'm moving let's resolve this
you're gonna take or not okay now
there's gonna be big trouble I think I
think there's probably a better way to
do this oh my goodness I don't like that
at all
Oh like how watch out for each - I am I
guarantee I guarantee I will scream if I
get made it on each - don't make me on
h2 please this is way too okay get the
Queens off get the Queens off please
before I get made in alright let's just
trade a little bit trade okay now
everything is fine
that pond was looking to take on each -
lets get this going King g3 maybe no
this ponds gonna advance they're down on
time let's throw a check in attack a
rock actually he's not being attacked I
was faking that without anything time
burners any moves no time back to
tournament twenty oh my goodness twenty
seventeen fourteen who a lot of time
remaining though a lot of time oh this
might turn out pretty good
right I might get hit with an error and
then I get some points for the air hit
me with the air and give me points
that's the plan
this game is not starting so what we do
is we do some homework we make every
second count we make every second count
we do some homework on the pack leader
this guy's the pack leader come on team
black let's go team black you could do
it team black is down on time and and
something else in position my game is
not starting Queen is hit
that's a free queen that's the freeze
queen now they're been boo more free
Queens this came come on is this gonna
be the rest of the tournament you get to
stare at this there we go
air time air time leaders leaders
leaders give me points Oh what did I get
three
I got nothing maybe did I get nothing I
have nine what did I have before that
game I can't recall maybe I should go
for a quick f7 strike the the
corresponding F to square Bishop ear
pins okay let's stop tricky pins yeah I
can't deal with that let's ask that guy
a question I'm okay I get this pun if
they get my pun I get I get their pun Oh
back up here Bishop takes I want to have
a clear Lane towards that okay I'm okay
with double pawns here I guess I'll have
to be let's do this come on just take
them out you know you want to take a
pinned piece
okay the Queen's are off opposite color
bishops how you proceed here I would
love to get this pawn advancing
successfully
let's go King help oh he was a free pawn
take like this otherwise I'm dropping
here and now there's gonna be a lot of
pressure let me take care mm oh no I'm
gonna sack this pawn I was fearful rook
g6 now they said least is a cozy home
cozy home heat five get my rook active I
have a ten-second advantage let's shut
down the bishop and fix this pawn
hangout there was some sneaky stuff
there get my other rook active a very
active rook and maybe I go forward with
an act of king my king he's a fighter
that's as far as he's going though oh
I'm to go any further
tricky discoveries watch out pigs
one Pig another Pig there's no time
there's no time
throw a check in just for fun no it's a
bad one back determined that wasn't
gonna finish 42 30 30 27 Wow I'm in 15th
I am in 15th place but there's a lot of
time a lot of time to lose
oh I'm dropping upon a lot of ways to
lose upon let's open this up maybe I
could put to use what exactly that's not
working
I believe in development but I can't
really do anything with that can I could
sneak around here Knight g4 stuff oh
this is this is scaring me I want to
open this up a bit more all right pawn
push I think I alright let's put an end
to that this is very soft right now g6
Bishop g4 with tempo but Bishop d3 I
might play here yeah Bishop here and
then this let's let's secure this point
there might be some tricks with the
knight moving and then no not quiet cuz
I could take the Queen with check we're
even with time this game is not ending
any time fast Bishop h6 I'm not worried
about my king position anymore rook c8
night b4 - see - he's a dead piece he's
he's staring at what he's staring at a
brick right here on e5 it's not good it
doubled can't Kontest this file actually
this and then there might be some pawn
breaks are over here where castle on
opposite sides so look to create open
files we're not good even gonna have
that I just need time burners and I'm
gonna throw my knight and 82 no matter
what no matter what all Riley back to
tournament Wow 56 42 36 39 confetti land
is top three land I need to get top
three Knight f3 there it is
Queens gambit declined alright let's get
my Center rollin my opponent lost some
control over the center with that
capture
and I might end up doing something
sneaky on h7 it could happen very
quickly Bishop takes as a threat my
opponents sniffing it right out they'll
Bishop here clean up I want to kick this
Knight out of here but let me take care
give no no no no no let's get this night
out of here that scares me I couldn't
get out of the way with check-in
important detail
let's build my Center there is no mate
just yet I don't think but my pawns are
Swiss cheese now watch out for that's
Swiss cheese balls don't look that one
up okay
my queen needs to do something else
let's trade let's trade
all right let's let's get rid of the
Queen get my king position up how's the
clock okay I have a good Bishop versus
their bad bishop bishop here I should
have done bishop their Bishop here's a
good move what does that even do that
was ridiculous move was the most
unconstructive move you're going to see
f3 Wow
you accomplished a ton I gotta get my
pawns going get my pawns going okay that
was helpful okay they got to go back
over my kings gonna be here in a good
spot I could kick the King back get out
of there that wasn't a good idea no I
don't want to do that 13 seconds yeah
just what I thought
okay I gotta come over here rook here
I'm he can't be stopped now he is a fast
pawn very fast oh he has stopped who am
I talking about me time burners this is
my lap this is the last time burner
right here it's all I have
it's the last time burner that's all I
needed
72 72 72 oh my goodness how are there
that many how are there that many um
points around the declined version of
the Smith Morra I need to strike at age
two four times I think
come back and I'm not gonna get there or
am i we're gonna still try for it clean
check clean check right here hmm okay
get material what sort of tricks are
gonna be over here I got to play g6 I
think no no no clean here clean here
we're gonna be having mate it's very
tempting to play that I think this night
needs to go I should have maybe
considered taking here my queen is hit
it's a little bit scary I'm opposite the
bishop but I want to take here next
mm-hmm like we might be trapped nice
here oh my goodness - Knights right here
this is so scary
the Queen has to come back to the fed no
watch over f7 watch out for f7 Knight
takes here would have been beautiful I
would have defended everything and hid
the Queen and the bishop in the night I
got a piece I should have taken here
first mm-hmm oh my goodness no way I'm
in a pin I want to keep my tricky Knight
around that's all I have is a tricky
Knight as long as he's around I feel
comfortable somehow as long as that
tricky Knight is around I somehow feel
comfortable you'll just have to believe
me he is the trickiest piece around okay
now it's time to get nervous actually
now my knight is there no need to be
nervous I have a knight 11 seconds okay
oh this pawn is dropping isn't he yes he
is prepared to run prepare to run over
here I can't do this the Queen and rook
are there five seconds don't get mated
whatever you do it's not gonna be mate
three seconds over here I need pre moves
pre moves no time back to tournament
this is that was an ugly ugly ugly game
okay stay focused here
can I go for some quick strikes quick
strike yes that's exactly what I needed
f7 strikes
ten I got fifty nine look out for f7 I
had to throw in something ridiculously
sneaky okay I know that feeling I
definitely know that feeling I have 7
and F too dangerous
I got a do redic I got a do very
ridiculous stuff here my opponent is not
going to go Kings side let's pin a piece
let's come back okay I should have maybe
played b5 the King oh right here tricky
night watch out
tricky night and that's the Queen back
to tournament that's exactly what I need
a 131 1090 675 I've played this guy
before and can I get again oh my
goodness whoa 130 110 just like that 93
no way this is not planned oh my
goodness f7 watch out for f7 whoa hang
on oh I just dropped a pun
no I didn't yeah I was should have what
am i doing my LightSquared bishop is
dumb wow he is a dumb dumb piece I got a
knight though they might resign it's a
free piece
okay I'm pinpointing this Queen b6 next
just punished pin so this would be
available I'm gonna hit it again I think
I want to do this now let's do this
break down this structure if he goes
everything's gonna fall he's gonna fall
very quickly let's defend here I want to
keep him around watch over f7 for some
reason I can't put my finger on it but I
think it's a good idea let's capture
like this keep my Jeep on around like
this and really oh it's taken the take
here
if King here I give a check and then I
take here as otherwise there's gonna be
recapture on f6 have everything covered
I have s have been covered Queen trade
Queen trade jump my nighty and I'm
hitting the rook and I wouldn't get to
take the rook I'm on the I'm on the
Brooke I want to get back rank me back
rank matin - they gotta take or they got
to move here to d1 dr. tournament 1:13
151 31 16 113 let halfway point 14
minutes remain 14 minutes remain okay I
really don't want to go for that
variation where I get the Queen and
they're on castled maybe I should have
just recaptured that right away so this
is some some type of Kings gambit to
break the pin I think I want to go Queen
side and pinpoint f7 now King side is
fine more direct I'm gonna take that
even though it subjects my King need
some pressure I was probably gonna go
there anyway unless that move is played
let's back up pawn push now I'm gonna
take I'm dropping this no I'm not okay
so they have wow air sac and stuff now
let's open it up I'm gonna give some
material back just to get rid of the
Queen's okay now that night where's he
gonna go for tricks I'm on this guy as
well let's defend if they take their in
a pin can i exploit that I want to kick
this defender way kick him away he could
take with check and then I could well
they're kind of stuck kind of stuck the
bishop here though I'm kind of stuck
it's not cool
I think it I want to free up my rook get
out of there okay they were converging
on this they forgot about that my pawn
was there though time burners 15 seconds
they flying where's the mates meetin two
or three okay it's makin three or
something back to term at 133 150 136
133 132
I would be nowhere near the top if I if
I didn't get those if I didn't throw in
that was sneaky f7 tricks I gotta throw
I gotta launch an H pun that's what this
is this time it's coming down to there's
so much of a lead by these other players
I gotta play wild you get that rook can
I get that rook is the big question I
want to take here a couple times I could
take here still a couple times the
bishop is the one who's unprotected no
no no I'm gonna take tonight these pawns
are doubled okay they did take I wanna
get developed now oh there's tension
between the Queen's okay I can't resist
I just can't resist okay my rook is
active just like that that's how he got
developed no need to castle no need to
Castle King up my light square Bishop is
going to play I promise you're going to
play buddy I just need to get some more
development in with my pawns watch this
square I want to do this my opponent was
all over that though okay my light
square bishop pawn push next let's take
this oh okay
they missed that one they missed that
one they went too quick with that tricky
Knight forks in every direction I want
to come here to trade maybe pick up the
night I do have the knight he's gone
Bishop check come back here grab their
last their last pawn anything is this
game even gonna finish keep marching
this pawn keep going thrown some checks
it's not gonna finish I just need time
burners really game is not gonna finish
back determine 150 200 oh my goodness
200 153 150 150 136 less than 11 minutes
remaining
okay let's avoid that trade Queen d2
queenside castle and Oh night night
right there would have been actually
pretty good night see for my dark square
Bishop is gone my night is not in a good
spot
get this pond rolling actually this is a
good pond break I think it can't be
taken okay I got a piece here but my
opponent flies just trade I get some
pieces here and they take spawn
I have this protected let's get the
Queen's off and then this Bishop I'm on
the rook and I just want to advance drop
back keep pushing him let's defend keep
pushing keep pushing
and let's get rid of a piece here mile
expert Bishop I don't want him to get
shut out okay now this is a lockdown
here let's give a check and then get
this other pawn up keep that rook can't
go anywhere they might resign maybe the
rook is stuck they resigned back
determined 200 190 173 158 less than 10
minutes remaining
those are some big scores up there 200
is a lot of points to already have okay
I need another quick kill somehow okay
let's stay on this diagonal h2 well
they're sniffing that without the
pressure here I still might want to do
that
let's give check and then still do this
they take its mate just like that on the
spot Knight f2 same story actually they
lose their queen if they take no and I
right there I was looking good you they
can't my night is still immune still
immune if you push I get h2 might be a
very tempting move to do same thing
night here I take and then I have stuff
on h2 we might be saying H 2 H 2 is
there that's exactly what I needed 200
193 15 games in 14 games in 14 games and
8
it's 42 seconds hooha to nowhere f-for
the bird back to tournament they
resigned to twenties 203 if we get
paired up that's gonna be a huge game
whoa to 22:03 eight minutes 25 seconds
remain pi pants PI pants I believe is
somebody who is also in the twitch chat
so he knows the square I'll be trying to
sneak into there it's still tough to
defend it is still tough to defend h2o
unless that plate is played but I have
play on the H file I could do this and
now I have my C pun around to watch over
night invasion pawn up I want to get my
queen to h3r or skewer my bishop I was
gonna say my bishop to h3 so if the
Queen doesn't move I'll keep that pin I
want to get this advancing I think can I
get that in successfully yes now I could
this diagonal is open now I can grab
some space since I got d5 in
successfully now these pawns could start
to roll like a pro pressure on this pond
and maybe support it with f4 I don't
want to walk into a self pin so quickly
though I'll do it now more pressure
should be placed on it no I think
attacking the pin piece would have been
better Knight here my queen be hit I'm
okay with the Queen exchange I'm not
Material his pawn is flying I should
have maybe stopped out no let's kick
this King out of his good position and
keep going next with checks shut the
door on the bishop grab some more space
this night could jump in my King is
gonna be central though
just come here anyhow and I I just want
to UM get rid of this Knight and then
focus on this square get my King here
I'm somehow okay with just giving up
that rook I want my King to have a
really good position and he does okay my
opponent's giving up some material if
that each file opens up there's gonna be
a problem it's gonna be a problem
and now they're kind of stuck they're
kind of stuck Bishop here and then mate
next back to turn for a second I thought
I was the one who had three seconds left
three seconds and changed not the case
though II for this is gonna be struggled
to try and get top three I think from
what I could tell with the know can I
get f seven again no way nights gonna
take you know not so great but I could
grab some space with a tempo to be
careful on this diagonal though my queen
could be hit I have this covered by my
bishop though let's get more development
in take with my pawn build my Center and
I could do this if they Castle they're
in trouble there they're already in
trouble
the queen is not having a good day now
she has to go back home I can do this
and get away with it rook here I take
the pawn feels like you could maybe even
give up my queen somehow to get this
back ring stuff the Queen can't really
do anything but go to b8 that's not
constructive if I can take this rook out
then there's problems for their King
looking for main threats if this Knight
moves it's a matin to on f8 unless he
goes to h7 let's get him out of my
territory and I think that said I want
to kick this night away and then make
use of that square g8 if Knight h7 isn't
played this is gonna be make no okay the
night is repositioning there it's open
this diagonal look clean check on out
Bishop takes and then I'll play Queen
age five the knight is pin so if pawn
takes it's that let me take that Bishop
mates right here me next is the threat
let's hit the Queen no no no no no no no
no no let's just take care queen takes
here was a possibility I got the Queen
maybe me in some way I'm not seeing it
just throwing anything time mate threat
on e7 it's close to unavoidable night
here I guess back to tournament 243 280
oh my goodness
282 52-43 I'm trying to get second I
don't think 280 is catchable four
minutes yeah that's probably not
catchable two games maybe three two
games maybe three remain and take like
that there Bishop keep my queen on this
all right let's just force White's hand
I want to get this in with tempo and I'm
close to doing that I get that in with
the tempo now if this pawn is no longer
here I have f5 available for my pieces
my knight in particular maybe wants to
jump into this square
I could establish a pawn on d4 and that
means that III will be a support point
and now he shut down the Queen is tied
down to the bishop I have b4 for my
knight and I want to play here pin the
night and then look to jump in here if
the Queen leaves I have this guy I don't
want to take I couldn't take that's what
I think that's why I should I shouldn't
take it's just double the pawns I want
to get play for my rook Queen is still
tied down in some way this night remains
pinned I want to jump in here and after
there's a capture I could have a
discovered attack against the rook my
bishop comes to life this guy is still
pin and he's passed I'm gonna be winning
material with e 2 e 3 or yeah III - E -
that's a fork and I take the rook and
then the knight and then the pawn here
take the rook I'm gonna get rid of the
tricky Knight first though
and recapture here probably no matter
what pawn push being sneaky against my
queen let's shut the bishop down first
here probably no matter what is okay
here no matter what back rank mates Oh
King here it's me with Bishop f6
it's a helpmate fact determined to 63 to
72 who this guy drop back to 72 72 63 if
I win this one I get 20 I'd have a lead
- 72 72 63 - 27 quick strike f7 I can't
go for that that'll that'll be stopped
east 6 is a very typical move although I
am winning material right now hang on
there's some sneaky stuff I could be
doing let's just open it up I want to
take that night and then get to f6 oh my
goodness I feel like there should be
something what does that even mean I
feel like there should be something
let's take him now and then give a check
he's got to be a pain right actually I
don't want to take the bishop coz brings
open the the UM I can't take with my
queen it helps the rook out so he's
passed and now I gotta go and reverse
gotta go in reverse get rid of that
night King position there's a bishop
check that could be thrown in yeah let's
get out of trouble okay my knight is
once this square shut this bishop down
he's close to trapped if Bishop takes I
take with my queen so I'm defending my
knight
let's interfere with the rooks
communication of the bishop and now I
got this bishop oh and I didn't take it
that was a mouse lip I still have him
though he couldn't go anywhere
surprisingly you couldn't go anywhere
still I want to take here in trade
Queens time is about even one minute
remains one minute remains
let's give a check
and then let's just double up if
everything defended where's the mate
okay
King position King position I should
have stopped that advance with h4 they
have a connected past pun much time oh
they're already calling it they called
the tournament I think it's third I
think if I'm lucky it's third yes third
please confetti ah man what a struggle
it must have been out of reach
yeah that's why they that's probably one
of the reasons why they called it it was
a little bit out of reach there right
are a lot about out of reach to 310 298
263 really strong turnout a lot of um a
lot of big guns up there
up top already good games oh all right